well folks as you can see i just met
with my team here
and uh secretary marcus uh homeland
security
and uh
my uh
my fema administrator uh
chris well they're on the ground in
kentucky yesterday
and i asked for a detailed briefing they
were able to see what they found
and uh they shared with me what they
learned and we discussed
how we can do uh
do more especially
so many of people are facing immense
immense loss
and we talked about uh
how we can accelerate and expand
uh federal assistance to those in
desperate need and you saw i mean some
of you have been there and you've seen
that you've been reporting on
television
you know the devastation you know before
and after
mrs mayfield kentucky i mean it's just
it's just devastating
and uh
we've already approved an emergency
declaration and a major disaster
declaration for kentucky i spoke with
the governor several times thus far
and this gives me the tools to provide
everything that we can
in the fedrat from the federal level
from expert search and rescue teams to
immediate and longer-term help with
housing
and clean up a whole range of things
and uh i stand ready to do the same for
the governors of other states matter of
fact i'm about to sign a
an emergency request from this
from illinois
the governor illinois went literally
when i finished the trip and signed that
and uh
and uh you know we've also asked fema
and the key departments surged from the
resources the thing they most need
are power water communication systems to
get back
to some sense of being able to
communicate with one another
as rapidly as they possibly can
and
as i said i intend to travel
uh to kentucky on wednesday
and uh with each passing day the human
impact this devastation is uh
just uh the depth of the losses are
becoming more and more apparent
this is a town with a relatively low
average income of under 20 000 a year
it's a town that has been wiped out but
it's not the only town
it's not the only town that path you see
moves all the way
up uh well over a hundred miles so
there's more than one route
and so uh um
you know
we were also seeing destruction
met with a lot of compassion i've told
everywhere they've gone they had people
volunteering talking asking for
that they not only
get help but how they can give some help
and uh so we continue to pray for
everyone
and kentucky and the other states are
affected and
particularly my heart goes out to
the governor of kentucky who's lost a
family himself
it's pretty rough stuff
and uh but we're going to get this done
we're going to be there as long as it
takes
to help and the combination of state
federal and
volunteer organizations do everything
from eventually not only clear the
debris but provide the necessary means
to move get schools reopened making sure
that homes are able to be rebuilt
etc so there's a lot a lot that needs to
be done
and it's in mostly kentucky here but not
only kentucky and so that's i just want
to let you know that's what i was doing
i haven't decided where i'm going yet
we're working out what i indicated to
the governor
when we talked about this two days ago
was that i don't want to be in the way
there's a lot going on and
and the when the president shows up
there's a long tail to follow an awful
lot of folks and i just don't want to do
anything other than be value-added
but i want you to know
that
this administration has made it clear to
every governor whatever they need when
they need it
when they need it make it known to me it
will get it to them as rapidly rapidly
as we can
and that's what we're doing here in
kentucky we're gonna have to go beyond
um what is available to the federal
government for example we're able to
fema can come up with up to thirty five
thousand dollars in housing restoration
well not a lot of thirty five thousand
dollar homes
in the meantime we can provide
everything from hotel rooms and
and and places where folks can live in
the meantime
but there's a lot to be done and uh
we're just getting it underway
but uh we're gonna work with all the
governors to make sure that we can't yes
mr president what do you believe your
own visit there can do for the people
who are affected by this and what is
your concern about the longest term
problems is it housing
what part of recovery do you worry about
well what i worry about most in a
circumstance like this because i've been
involved in
uh responding to a lot of disasters as a
senator as vice president now as
president just this year
is uh the peace of mind of people being
able to actually put their head on a
pillow
lie down on a bed and be able to
know their kids are going to be okay and
and so
with the this is a narrow path
the devastation is just stunning i mean
there's nothing left standing basically
along the path that goes all the way
through
you know do you have that other let me
ask you
show that other
in terms of
housing
because i think this is the best way to
illustrate just how precise it's coming
you go to the one that goes all the way
up and this takes you
so if you take a look why don't you
point out where we are here
you take a look where mayfield and
bowling green is that's not we're not
talking about
mayfield now but all these
yellow dots here along the way are
residents
and they've been wiped out
they've been wiped out commercial
and government
historical sites and you know industrial
sites it's been wiped out do you mind
putting one back up for mayfield
if you take a look
mayfield sits
and that where that square is on the
left
well look at all this is just make the
the city of mayfield
residential commercial exempt
government and historical agriculture et
cetera just i mean they're they're
they're gone
and some of you are probably already
down here it's just devastating and so
and i worry quite frankly about
how can i say it
the mental health of these people
you come home and you see that if you
made it and if you haven't if you lost
someone in the meantime
you know
thank god it doesn't seem like the
numbers are quite as high as we're
anticipating but they're high
you come home you've lost your husband
wife mother father children somebody
along the line
and what do you do where do you go
it's not like if you're making sixteen
thousand dollars a year you you know get
in the plane and head to your relative
in uh
you know washington
but i i mean i mean literal that's what
worries me most
the uncertainty
and it really is something that i've
observed in every major disaster i've
watched and been on the ground to see it
just is it's just you can see it
people's faces
so we just want them to know that we're
going to stay as long as it takes to
help them and there's three ways that we
can help one
is the federal agencies that are
available
and that's already underway
and for example they're setting up
[Music]
in all these places for example they're
going to be uh
roughly how many disaster centers you
think we'll have in the states
so in one place a citizen can go
there will be essentially an arms
bootsman what i said to the governors
and it surprised me that they
pleased me but surprised me that they
repeated it is that
for example i told the governor of
kentucky i not only
i'm not expecting you to know all you
need
let us tell you what you can't ask for
that you haven't asked for
let us let us do our job i mean these
these large government agencies like the
federal or state governments it's hard
for people to understand sometimes let
me go in and tell you what you can ask
for
and so there is the gov the federal
government the state government there's
also the non-profits out there that have
been in fact involved in all these
disasters around the country and they
can provide help and assistance right
now for example i'm told i hope i'm not
misspeaking
that the school in mayfield is being
used for shelter now it didn't get wiped
out but it is not going to be able to be
functioned as a school
so
how do you get these kids back in school
rooms how do you get some semblance of
normalcy again and so we're working like
the devil i'm very uh uh very pleased
with the work that
the
female director chris fall has done and
i and i i know that uh
homeless security's done reached out to
these folks they know we're there
and i just want to make sure there is no
sense on the part of anyone
in these affected areas
that they are asking something that they
shouldn't ask for
ask for whatever you think you need and
we'll find out and if we can't provide
it to you through a government agency
we'll do our best to find out private
agencies that can help
from churches to red cross to
a whole range of institutions
but it's just um
it's just it's like when i was
walking through the neighborhoods in
louisiana i mean see the looks on
people's faces
you go to the corner where there were
the houses just gone
people standing in their yards crying
and this this was two days after
uh the storm went through
so it really is devastating this is the
united states of america though the
thing that pleased me with
every every one of my staff who were
down there came back at least today and
called me on the phone and said you know
people are all ready to help each other
or are you asking you know how can i
help too so
that's what i worry most about it's just
getting some peace of mind and say look
there is there is a way to get from here
to there
it's disaster now but there's a way to
get there we're gonna do everything we
can and i'm sure
i i believe the congress will respond to
that extraordinary need we don't have
yes sir um how much of a factory do you
think that climate change was in this
and do you think that would be part of
the argument do you think people like
senator manchin about why the bill back
better bill
no i'm not going to make that argument
with him about this look joe understands
joe had as much empathy and concern for
these folks i mean he's been through
some real disasters in west virginia he
understands
um and the honest to god truth is we're
discussing this i've spent a lot of time
on climate issues
and
i i said we have to be very careful we
can't say with absolute certainty
that it was because of climate change so
i'm going to be talking with with the
environmental protection agency and i'm
going to talk about other agencies to
determine in fact matter of fact some of
it has to do with el nino there's a lot
of things that we don't know for certain
and i don't want to say anything
that is not precisely true
what is certain
it is one of the worst tornado disasters
we've had in the country
and the second thing is certain is that
it is unusual
it is unusual how it happened
how many places it touched down and the
length of the path so that's all i'm
prepared to talk about right now yes
thank you mr president uh this is all
happening in the middle of pandemic
how are you thinking about will these
places need more resources because
they're also going to be dealing with
you know possibly rising cases possibly
hospitals being overloaded
yes we're gonna look we have i have my
the entire federal team
not just the folks going in and making
sure there's still people without
leaving anybody still breathing under
debris
that's the immediate immediate urgent
urgent thing and just to get the food
water
to people who don't have it and there's
no place to get it
so that's number one but number two
there's a whole range of things
including the virus
including the virus
and the hospitals i i've gotten a report
but not the detail i need about the
hospitals along the path of this
of of this tornado but you know it's
gonna we're gonna have to
i'm sure
i'm gonna be asked to i'm gonna be
asking my team
to set up uh uh um
sites for booster shots and a whole
range of things and people still
the the worst part is their life has to
go on as if nothing happened
because they've still got to take care
of those needs from
getting their kid going to get in school
to whether or not they're going to be
able to collect an unemployment check
are they going to be in this you know
all those issues
but one of those issues will be
public health as it relates to
copenhagen
[Music]
no look i told you when i speak to
senators to try to or house members
or governors or any other elected
official to try to convince them that
what i'm
proposing makes sense and it's not
inconsistent with what they believe
i do that and then i'll discuss it
afterwards okay
[Applause]
thank you sir thank you